[Music]
stay where you are
you'll move who are these people we need
to get out of here are they with you not
an instrument shot
stop
sorry Helena Dr Jones it's over here
what do you want
[Music]
he's on the roof find another way up
Matthew Jones I'm not gonna hurt you
[Applause]
I need to introduce I'm retiring well in
that case what are we drinking same for
the goddaughter God told me you found
something on a train during the war a
dial that could change the course of
history why are you chasing the thing
that drove your father crazy
he'll move please get out of here
sorry
[Music]
help yours get him
Hitler made mistakes and with this I
will correct them all you stole it then
you stole it and then I stole it it's
called capitalism
thank you
passenger seat belt there might be some
tablets you've taken your chances made
your mistakes
and now a final Triumph
Indiana Jones a few times in my life
we're seeing things
I'm gonna torture with voodoo
shot nine times
included once by your father
ah sorry
[Music]
and I've been looking for this
all of my life
[Music]